welcome back or maybe you didn't even
last watch the last view but anyway we
are in problem number 15 15 the Acme
plumbing company will send a team of
three plumbers to work on a certain job
the company has four experienced
plumbers and four trainees so for
experienced and four trainees for
trainees i spelled tree and i split
right right if a team consists of one
experienced plumber and two trainees how
many such teams are possible so we're
going to send three plumbers right three
plumber so it's one two three and one of
them has to be experienced right and
then these are inexperienced these are
trainees so this is the team you know
one experience in two trainees and now
we're going to have to pick from a set
of let's say let's because we could pick
from a set let's say it my my for
experienced plumbers or plumbers a b c d
these are experienced experienced and
let's say my trainees are e f g h so
these four trainees so how many
different experienced plumbers can i
have heading up the team well there's
four possibilities right so i can
there's four different people i can
stick in here four choices or four
possibilities now independent of who i
put into the experience lot how many
trainees let's say this is training slot
1 and training slot 2 not that there's a
difference so now if I'm if I'm picking
for who can go into training slot 1 how
many choices do I have well I have four
choices because none of them have been
staffed yet so i can put four people
here no not for people i can i can i'm
putting one person but i can pick one of
four so there's four possibilities here
once I've already filled training slot
one one of these people are going to
disappear then the set is going to be
it's going to be one less right there's
only going to be three trainees left
once I filled slot one
so how many trainees can i put in slot 2
well i can there's only three
possibilities i can put because i
already stuck one in slot and what in
slot 1 so there's four possible
experience people for possible choices
for training in slot 1 and then since
one training will already have been
staffed and slot 1 there's only three
choices for slot too so it's 4 times 4
times 3 so what is that 4 times 12 which
is 48 possibilities next problem and the
trick here is just realizing that once
you staff one of the trainees you only
have three left that you can put in the
other one and the other the second
trainee slot next problem problem 16 all
right we got some circles going on here
let me draw a circle so they have one
circle like that then they have a bigger
circle that looks something like oh not
enough I know let me undo that edit undo
okay let me see if I can make it more
even that's pretty good pretty good okay
and let me fill it in with a pleasant
color all right the figure above
consists of two circles that have the
same center if the shaded area is 64 pie
so the shaded area is 64 pie shaded area
is 64 pi square inches and the smaller
circle has a radius of 6 inches so the
smaller circle has a radius of 6 so that
distance right there is six what is the
radius in inches of the larger circle so
we want figure out well we have a free
radius of the larger circle let's call
that I know it's called radius of the
larger circle I'll do in this green
color it's called that X so what's going
to be the area of the shaded circle well
how would we figure it out if we knew
the radius of the larger circle what
would be the area of the large circle
area of the large circle minus the area
of the small circle is going to equal 64
pie
right because the if the whole thing was
filled in MO voor whatever color this is
then that'll just be the area of the
large circle but we're subtracting out
the area of the small circle to get the
the move region so what's the formula
for the area of the large circle it's pi
times its radius squared so we're
already set that radius to be equal to X
so it's pi x squared and that's what
we're trying to figure out in this
problem minus the area of the small
circle will see area the small circle
what's radius is 6 so it's PI R squared
so it's pi x 6 squared and that is going
to equal to 64 pi and you know just to
simplify things we can just divide both
sides 4 by pi just to get them out of
the way so this you know all the terms
you can get rid of the pie but you don't
have to do that that's just simplifies
things for my simple mind so we get x
squared minus 36 is equal to 64 AD 36 to
both sides you get x squared is equal to
100 so X could be equal if you just
solved it it would be plus or minus
stand and of course a radius can't be
negative so it's plus 10 so X is 10 or
the radius of the larger circle is 10
next problem problem 1717 if PR and s
are three different prime numbers
greater than 2 P R and s let me just
write them down p RN s three different
prime numbers greater than 2 and n is
equal to P times R times s how many
factors including 1 and n does n have
how many factors this is a good problem
so let me let me put this this is
essentially the prime factorization this
is the prime factorization of n right
and we want to know oh we want to know
how many how many positive factors
including 1 and n right so what are all
of all of the factors here so if we just
made a factor tree obviously 1 times
let's make all let's make a combination
of all the numbers they can when i
multiply the pair can equal n so 1 times
n is equal to n another number that
would equal n is PR PR times s would
also equal n right because obviously p
times R times s is n so P times R times
s is then I'm but I'm saying p times R
is a number right hopefully that makes
some sense similarly we could say that p
x RS is equal to n same logic and I'm
saying r times s is a number right some
number and then finally we could say
that SP x r SP with SP is a number is
also equal to n right so all of these
all of these numbers that i said one two
three four five six seven eight all of
these numbers are factors of n so that's
how many factors there are there are
eight factors including one and n if
this seemed a little bit abstract to you
try it out with some numbers let's say
let's say actually actually that's
that's the best way you could do it if
this was too abstract you could say well
what if P is three r is five and s is
seven then what is n well n is going to
be 15 times seven so n is 15 times seven
what is that 70 + 35 n is 105 the
finance 101 x 105 PR this would be 15
times seven this would be three times 35
is that right 50 no sorry 85 no no sorry
if 5 times 7 is 35 times 3 35 times 3 35
times 3 alright 105 right
so we could we would write write three
times 35 and SP SP is 2121 times 5 so
those would be the actual numbers so
hopefully that makes a little bit more
sense to you but this is another way you
could do it in a general way it looks
like I'm running out of time so i will
do number 18 in the next in the next
video but they just a this is a little
bit of a non intuitive problem just
remember this is the prime factorization
and then you can construct it's kind of
what i call the normal factorization you
can construct that by just taking
combinations of the prime numbers and
hopefully the the actual numbers make a
little bit more sense to you see in the
next video